the highest court in the land the
verdict unanimous the decision chillin
for the prime minister his reasons for
suspending Parliament not good enough
this prolonged suspension of
parliamentary democracy took place in
quite exceptional circumstances the
effect on the fundamentals of our
democracy was extreme no justification
for taking action with such an extreme
effect has been put before the court the
Supreme Court ruled Boris Johnson had
abused his power when he suspended
Parliament in the run-up to brexit day
the decision to advise Her Majesty to
parade Parliament was unlawful because
it had the effect of frustrating or
preventing the ability of Parliament to
carry out its constitutional functions
without reasonable justification the
five-week suspension to October the 14th
unlawful and undone Parliament has not
been probed this is the unanimous
judgment of all eleven justices those
who brought the case delighted and
demanding MPs get back to work the
Supreme Court has unanimously ruled that
Parliament has not been proved to stop
us members of parliament such as myself
and my colleagues from resuming
immediately the important job of
scrutinizing this minority Tory
government as we hurtle towards
breakfast they won't have to wait long
I've instructed the House authorities to
undertake such steps as are necessary to
ensure that the House of Commons sits
tomorrow and that it does so at 11:30
a.m. this man's position looking rather
precarious but the real Boris Johnson in
New York for now
defiant his challenges in court the
enemies of Pratt sit I strongly disagree
with what the justices have found I
don't think that it's right but we will
go ahead and of course the parlament
will come back but I think the most
important things we get on and deliver
brexit on October the 31st and there's
clearly a the claimants in this case are
determined to try to to frustrate that
number tan clear mr. Johnson's stay in
put political opponents have other ideas
I invite Forrest Johnson in the historic
words to consider his position and
become the shortest serving Prime
Minister has ever been on the face of it
this couldn't get worse for the Prime
Minister he's lost a by-election he's
lost his parliamentary majorities lost
every vote he's brought to the floor of
the Commons and now the most humbling
defeat of all he's lost in the Supreme
Court but where does it leave him what
does it actually change Parliament and
mr. Johnson are still in gridlock he
won't resign they won't give him an
election until he agrees to delay brexit
and all the while we are heading for an
even bigger legal political
constitutional collision on the bumpy
road to brexit mr. Johnson being dragged
back onto the brexit battlefield and
back to the despatch-box here to not
just face furious MPs but to face them
down he still believes the people are
behind him Beth Rigby Sky News
Westminster